Adult Swim's runaway sensation wrapped
up its third season in October 2017 and
fans have been waiting patiently for
fourth season ever since fortunately a
brand-new batch of Rick and Morty
episodes is finally in production and on
its way to television here's everything
we know so far for patient Rick and
Morty fans the long wait for new
multi-generational universe hopping
adventures is nearly over in May 2000
nineteen Adult Swim's parent company
Warner media held its upfront
presentation in New York fans hoped
against hope that there would be some
good news about the long-awaited fourth
season of Rick and Morty and Warner
deliver announcing that Rick and Morty
would return at the end of the year
everybody Rick and Morty is back brand
new season 4 in November 2019 this year
we're gonna do it this year but when
exactly in November 2009 teen Warner
didn't say only that the series would
show up sometime in the weeks or days
before or after Thanksgiving with some
exceptions most American television
shows don't take too long of a break
between seasons most broadcast Network
shows run from September to May while
cable channels or streaming services
might drop a 13-episode season of a
series in the spring and then returned
with another 13 about a year later but
the wait between seasons 3 and 4 of Rick
and Morty has been comically
frustratingly long delays are nothing
new with Rick and Morty
about 15 months passed between the end
of season 1 and the beginning of season
2 and there was a good year and a half
between season 2 and the beginning of
season 3 the two year wait for season 4
however is easily the longest in series
history series co-creators Justin
roiland and Dan Harmon have commented on
the sometimes lengthy wait for Adult
Swim to order new episodes and the
complex process of negotiating for a
budget large enough to give the show
quote the attention it deserves in March
2018 Harmon guested on Kevin Smith and
Scott Moser SModcast at the time neither
he nor roiland were actively working on
creating more Rick and Morty episodes he
explained that the reason was simple
enough business problems saying it's
because of a little something
old contract negotiations and it's
gotten complicated this time around but
it all worked out in the end
two months later Adult Swim ordered a
whopping 70 new episodes of Rick and
Morty
that means roiland & Harmon are
contractually obligated to churn out
Rick and Morty for years to come via
seasons have run for 10 or 11 episodes
at one point during the production of
season 3 Harmon had hoped to produce 14
episodes but the schedule forced to cut
back in late 2017
he told Entertainment Weekly that he'd
like to give that idea another try Rick
and Morty's creative team doesn't have
too hard of a time keeping its voice
cast under contract that's because the
two main characters are voiced by Justin
roiland who is also the show's
co-creator and primary creative force
Marty helped me Morty helped me Rick
perfect Sarah Chalke who is voiced Beth
Smith for the show's entire run
confirmed to Entertainment Tonight
Canada in April 2009 teen that she's
coming back to there will also be some
big names joining the small Club of Rick
and Morty guest voices which includes
John Oliver Christina Hendricks and
Danny Trejo Sam Neill is also apparently
making a voice contribution on Halloween
2018 Neil tweeted I enjoyed working with
Rick and Morty last week
finally anime 2019 interview with
Hollywood Life Roylott broke the news
that Paul Giamatti would soon be
recording lines for an upcoming episodes
and you know what god bless you Paul
Giamatti you're a hero
an angel no sigh Ghana the upcoming
fourth season of Rick and Morty is still
in production as royland Harmon and the
crew barrel into the future and a
promised premiere date of sometime in
November 2000 19 that's only a few
months away but as of july 2019 there's
no official Rick and Morty trailer
available however Adult Swim has put out
several fifteen second promo commercials
for the upcoming season what the hell is
a promo commercial anyone disposable
advertisement it's meaningless it has it
doesn't matter the first was a trippy
montage that showed Rick devouring Morty
and various animal forms the second
released on the Rick and Morty Twitter
accounts is similarly trippy but with a
fourth of July theme happy birthday
America notify the president what do I
tell him tell him the truth
tell him Rick and Morty just blew off
America anyone who watches Adult Swim
knows that these kinds of promos are a
common form of station ID designed to
show off their lineup without any direct
connection to episode content but it
does serve as a taste of new footage for
fans hungry to know about the creative
head space in which the Rick and Morty
team are currently operating you know
besides the usual I have to need another
shot just kidding joking this is gonna
be the whiz kid take what will actually
happen in season four show creators
Justin roiland and Dan Harmon are
keeping quiet and a 2019 interview with
Hollywood Life neither of them were any
help jokingly riffing on Harmons story
circle writing process that forms the
basis of every episode Oh Rick is gonna
learn a very valuable lesson and pay a
heavy price Rick and Morty storyboard
artist Douglas Olson posted some tweets
about evil Morty eventually saying guess
we'll just have to see how his
administration is faring this upcoming
season another fan favorite bit could
make a return on February 8 2019 roiling
posted an Instagram picture from inside
a recording booth with the caption IDC 3
maybe the Rick and Morty mastermind
might be teased in a third
interdimensional cable episode what are
you doing
a sequel I don't understand yeah me
neither hardcore Rick and Morty fans who
want to see an episode of the show's
forthcoming season a little early may
want to drop some cash on a trip to the
2019 Adult Swim Festival like Coachella
but with way more weird comedy the event
takes place on November 15th and 16th in
Los Angeles the festival's biggest draw
is likely the screening of a brand-new
episode from season four Rick and Morty
organizers haven't said if it's the
season premiere or an installment from
later on in this new batch of episodes
but it is the first debut of any new
Rick and Morty episode since 2017 the
holes opening
there's the tips a lot more where that
came from to check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]